I want to ask you about the Oscars
obviously is been a lot of talk about
the Oscars this year and some
controversy you you thought that there's
some movies that got overlooked is are
there any movies that you thought man
that's a great movie I think that should
have been included it should have been
nominated but it wasn't sure um you know
obviously trainwreck and I'm not just
saying that because judge here and I
want to pitch him a movie later no I
it's funny because I don't I don't see
that many movies but I saw I saw this
one movie tangerine which was a really
it was a really good movie that I feel
like didn't really get any sort of
consideration and I and it was this
movie it was shot on an iPhone but if
you look at it doesn't look like I'm
shot on iPhone and it's a story about
transgender sex workers in Los Angeles
and was really moving and funny and I
the only reason I saw it was I was
invited to a screening and I rarely get
invited to movie screenings but when I
do I usually say no but this one was
close to home so I was like whatever
right how close to home like like three
blocks yes you could you'll go to a
screening if you can walk there yeah so
I went to screening but I didn't know
anything about the movie and so usually
at those things they make you do like
press and they have you go through a
press line so I was like well let me
look up and see what this movie is
because I didn't know what it was at
that point so I went on the internet and
I looked up tangerine and there's a
weird thing that the same time that
tangerine came out there's another movie
called tangerines that also came out
around the same time and tangerines was
very serious drama about two soldiers
one Estonian and one Georgian soldier
who were trapped in a house together and
you don't know if they're gonna kill
each other and that was the one that I
did an internet search on
I didn't I didn't read things quickly
enough it was three blocks away I didn't
do my due diligence so I learned a lot
about a Baltic conflict and then got to
the press line and the movie the movie
had premiered on Pride weekend and so
this reporter came up to me and was like
this is a fitting movie to be watching
for Pride weekend and I was like wait a
minute did you just blow the whole movie
just like we I hate who you are as a
person but I love who you are and so I
was just like I like I got really mad
and I was I was just saying I was just
like you just ruined this movie and in
my head like still nothing I didn't I
didn't know there was another movie
called tangerine and I see other people
going through the press line and there
were a lot of transgender people going
through the press line and I rarely see
transgender people in a press line so I
was like oh wow that's really amazing
like look at that like all these all
these people who are coming to see this
movie and I didn't realize that Baltic
conflicts really resonated with the
trans was like this I didn't realize
like I you know it's a different Georgia
yeah you have we have there's a picture
of you on the press line looking
completely confused and this is real
[Applause]
that was I think that was the moment
when they were like it's a different
movie it's still free though and it was
a great movie and it should have gotten
it should have gotten it will now I
don't think I don't think anything wants
a bump from me given the Grammy campaign
I just did for that I think you're in
good shape
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos